Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from March 14th,
2016 how are you doing? How's
it going? How are you, oh,
is that a new blouse? What did she
tell you? Did something different? Um,
is there anything worse than watching
somebody do that? You know, coming up,
when they take the two women meet, right?
And they grab each other by both hands.
Right? And then they look at you
and they fucking hold the hands out.
I think I've talked about this before.
Look at you. What are you doing? You know,
secretly hating the woman
cause she looks better.
You know I can't you be like guys,
we just look each other in the attic.
I said Pussy,
I don't know. I'm talking about,
oh Billy fucking cuisine over here.
I want to try and make
Gnocchi this week or no? Yeah.
Where the fuck you supposed
to pronounce it? Um,
doesn't seem too fucking hard. Right?
So anyways, we got these old pants,
right? Like everything in my
life. It's fucking old, right?
I'm old and everything I own is old.
Cause I bought it when I was young. Um,
so I guess the Teflon or whatever, the
no ship with you whenever it was square,
Ted scraped off over the years and was
flaking up and somebody told my lady that
it was getting in our food.
So now of course all my God,
we got to get rid of them. We're
going to get cancer, you know,
or eaten Teflon fucking omelets.
Evidently. I don't know.
I didn't taste it. My fucking
omics bomblets or rather delicious.
I didn't feel any Plano
crunchy. Like, wait a minute.
What was that? What was that?
What was that onions? Or was that
part of the frying pan? I can't tell.
It's such a similar taste.
Eggs and parts of the frying pan,
you know, I don't know.
I figured, you know,
with the amount of booze and I
do whatever that, that, you know,
Teflon that went to my system got
eaten up by the fucking my liquid diet.
Right. But whatever. So now we got to
go get a fucking frying pan. So I go,
all right. You know, we, we,
we have one nice one and then
we had like three shit ones.
So the three shit ones,
I guess we're giving us cancer because
someone who isn't a doctor saw,
saw the pants and told us that that
was what was, what was happening.
So we threw those outs and all that.
I'm sure those are going to be fucking
hitting some octopus on the fucking head
when they dump it into the ocean soon
and ups and now I'm going to go buy some
more,
right?
I already had what I needed and I throw
it out and I got to go buy some more.
Right. Classic fucking
capitalism. It's how it works.
It's how we keep it going. That's how
we keep the plates spinning. You go out,
you buy what you need and
then when you have it,
you throw it out and then your rebuy it.
And the second people stopped doing that,
this whole country goes down the shitter.
That's it. That's how simple it is.
All these fucking stupid
terrorists over there, you know,
who do think they got to come over here
and Bama. So all they gotta do is just,
she just start sending leaflets over here,
telling us not to buy stuff.
Hey, wait, you already own that? You
don't need to buy that. Keep the money.
Treat yourself. Put your feet up. Don't
go to the mall. Relax. You just said,
you know, propaganda like we used
to one them in the wars, right?
We drop a drop little leaflets,
you know,
I would love to read one of
those everything together.
They ain't fucking pictures
of those wartime leaflets
to try to get people like,
I don't understand. How the fuck
are you going to do that? Like,
I don't think I could have a flyover.
Yankee stadium with leaflets telling
people to become red sox fan. So like,
how do you,
during a fucking war when the country
that's bombing your country is going to
send you a leaflet. What the fuck
does it say on it? Yeah. Hey,
sorry about most of your
relatives. Uh, anyways,
you want to come over to our side?
We could get you a ham sandwich.
Them fucking smoky. Um,
all right. Let's see.
World War,
two leaflets.
We flipped propaganda. All right.
Let's read a couple of these.
Let me see if this would make
you fucking switch sides.
Go from Red Sox to the
Yankees are fucking Dodgers.
The giants are fucking avalanche to
the fucking red wings or a Michigander.
Hi.
You get, um, all right.
Oh, Jesus Christ. Lay this one.
Why are you German? Still fighting? Not
that's, that's no way to get the reader.
The question is extremely
difficult to answer.
Did they understand that these
people spoke to spoke German?
You're going to write it?
Yeah.
This is almost over my head and
I speak the fucking language. Uh,
why are you German still
fighting on via you, Jeremy?
Still fighting is the fear of blues.
The fucking brains out and x
two is six of a chip. There are,
the question is extremely
difficult to answer. In fact,
there is no reasonable answer to
it at all. You go on fighting,
although you cannot,
I should believe fucking click on the
page here so I can read this a little
bigger. Oh, and then it always
disappears. Doesn't it always disappear?
You just click on it. Where'd it
go? Okay. There we go. All right.
You go on fighting,
although you can not
help but realize that Germany
is losing the war. Wow.
Jesus. This would make me want to be
gay. I fuck these fucking assholes. Uh,
you go on fighting. Although you know
that every day, which the war still lasts,
meets new destruction to your homeland,
new danger and new hardships to
your family. You go on fighting.
Although it is clear that the only
people interested in the pro prolonged
[inaudible] of the war, someone's going
to read that in a second language.
I can't even read it.
Prolongation of the war or the party
leaders who want to delay at any price,
the consequences,
which the Nazi defeat is inevitably
going to have for them personally.
In other words, we're
going to hang them. Uh,
remember that your dear
ones want you back alive.
Remember also that there is only one
safe way home the way through allied
captivity.
You know,
we had a lot of balls dropping these
after we were firebombing fucking cities,
Huh? Yeah. You know,
I know we just burned.
You're all fucking city to the ground
and evidently he didn't die screaming in
agony. A, the only way for you to avoid
that is to, uh, become our prisoner.
According to the Geneva Conventions,
which has been recognized by Brazil,
you will have the following
privileges and allied captivity.
Oh Jesus. This is the, this is the
classic checks in the fucking mail.
You will be removed immediately
from the battle zone.
You will get the same food as
allied troops. If six sick,
you will be treated in the
same hospitals as our soldiers.
And after the end of the war, you will
go home as soon as possible. Well,
that's pretty vague. As soon as we,
uh, decide when you can fucking leave.
Did anybody believe a word of that? I
didn't. I wouldn't do it. I was like,
you know what the fuck you want
these fucking guys are doing.
They want us to surrender
cause they don't want
us to kill more of them.
They're just going to fucking
kill us. You know what? I
all GI, he speaks the truth. Um,
that was me in a foxhole
with a Boston accent,
talking to somebody who sounds like
Hans and Franz. How'd you like that?
He didn't think that was coming on
the old podcast there. Did Ya? Um,
the fuck did I start talking
about World War II leaflets?
I was talking about buying a frying pan.
Oh yeah.
So I get down the street
driving down the old road there.
Okay. It's a Sunday evening.
I'm like, you know what,
I'm going to knock this shit out before
Monday comes around and all these
assholes have to go to work. You
know what I mean? Oh, I'm sorry.
It's an election year. All these hard
work, Joe, six backs, they put that pants.
Um, anybody who was in my ways and
ask is there either a cunt. Okay.
And I wish I was more enlightened to
realize that I'm just impatient. But, uh,
that's, you know, it hasn't
happened yet. So anyways,
so I'm driving down the fucking
road crews and along, you know,
and all of a sudden,
you know,
they're doing road construction and then
it's just this massive fucking traffic
jam. And I knew I had to do the podcast
tonight cause I'm doing some bullshit
tomorrow morning and I'm just like,
it can you can kids fucking city can
it just ever give you a fucking break,
you know,
I got to tell you something.
All these shit where they talk
about New York, you know if I can,
my dad,
oh that shit.
You know they're always blow in New
York about how fucking difficult it is.
I got to tell you. Okay, there's
an outsider from Massachusetts.
I've lived in both places.
New York is definitely has
its way grinding you down,
but there is no place like
fucking Los Angeles Dude,
this fucking city is,
it's just, it's brutal.
It just fucking, it never,
never lets up, you know.
And then the whole time you're just baking
in the sun of the exact same weather
every fucking day.
And everyone in the east coast comes
out here and they're like here for five,
six days. I'm like, God, this is great.
This is great. Yeah, this is great.
For six days it's fucking great.
But every day waking up that fucking Sun,
Sun sign, Sun Burn. It
down on your fucking head.
I'm telling you this fucking place.
And you combine that with being in this
business that I'm in trying to fucking
move ahead. It is. It is brutal. Fucking
brutal and all that shit. You know?
I can't tell you how many fucking New
York comedians have moved out here and
then move back. I moved back. First Time
I came out of it, I couldn't take it.
I was like, I gotta get the Fuck Outta
here. I'm telling you, they're always saw.
Ah, you know, New York is so fucking
real. I'll fuck you. Fuck you. Bullshit.
You couldn't take it.
You couldn't take it and you wanted to
move back to you familiar surroundings to
only be 20 minutes away from
your grandmother's special sauce.
That's why the fuck you move back.
All right.
You dumb fucking leather coat. It
was a pizza sucks out here. You know,
I'm telling you, if I had to vote,
which is a tougher city to live in,
I would definitely say Los Angeles over
New York. It is. Fuck you Nazi. That's it.
Fucking catches on fire out here. There's
mudslides, this fucking earthquakes,
you know, in New York. What's great about,
but I'm just talking basically trying to
make it in show business to live in New
York, in show business, which
is what is great about it is,
is you can get on the subway and stand
amongst a bunch of regular people,
real people, right? And then you get
to feel this feeling that you're real,
that you're not this big
show Biz fucking phony.
Who wants their own Goddamn TV show.
Yeah. New York. It's so fucking real.
Look at that chair. Look how real
that fucking chair is. Right. Um,
I just think because you know,
everybody's all mixed into fucking gather.
He ride on the subway that
these New York show Biz people,
they just automatically think
that they're there. You know,
everybody here is all plastic and phony
because you come out to la and the whole
place looks like a fucking
movie set. Right? You sit there,
you know you'd ride on the subway and you,
you sit next to some fucking,
I don't know,
some construction worker,
union guy with his hard hat getting
ready and you, you start, yeah, yeah.
One of these guys now. No, you're
not. You're in show business.
You're a big fucking phony,
right?
You're on your way to puppet puppeteer
or school or whatever the fuck it is.
You're doing your little song and dance
because you don't want to have a job.
Sorry, I shouldn't have said
all that shit. But you know,
I really should have said that having
seen all the bullshit that I've,
I've seen like, you know,
Bernie Sanders talking about,
I don't know what the fuck he was
talking about. Like I don't think it's,
you know,
a good way to try to bring black and
white people together by talking about how
white people have never lived in a ghetto
because automatically you just going
to put them into a defensive
posture where they're going,
they're going to sit there and think
about all the shit that they've gone
through and then they get, and then
to go, they're going to get upset.
You know what I mean? Um, yeah.
I don't, generally speaking,
white people do not live in ghettos,
although I don't think other races of
people do not live in the middle of
fucking nowhere off the Appalachian trail.
You know,
washing their clothes in a fucking
bathtub. Sharon, a pair of shoes,
some of that fucking horrific
poverty that I've seen, um,
that most of these fucking
politicians will never see.
I don't think it's one of
these fucking politicians.
They should go on the road and open for
a fucking comedian who's traveling to
all these different
than you will see shit.
You can't fucking believe
Koc levels of poverty.
exist in this country. Um,
I don't want to name cities,
but a,
there's some places
down South Jesus Christ.
I remember one time I was,
I drove from Indianapolis to Nashville
and there was someplace in southern
Kentucky.
I was running out of gas and I pulled
over and they'll fucking humanity.
My God, I swear to God, there was
something in the fucking drinking water.
I've never seen it.
Always just like I do.
I describe these people without
just absolutely insulting them. Um,
I dunno, it was just like, uh, you know,
when somebody is like so dumb,
you get nervous, you know,
they start talking to you and they're
looking at you and they're your,
you can tell they're just smart enough
that they know that you think that
they're dumb and you're trying not
to fucking give it away. You know,
she just kind of puts your eyebrows
up like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
You try to get out of the
fucking conversation. Yeah.
It was like an entire gas station of that.
Even the person running the gas station,
um,
and this was off a major highway, you
know, there was a subway, you know,
you know when you get drive
in the middle of nowhere,
you don't ever go into just some
fucking, you know, mom and pop place.
You don't want to do that. What you
do is just stay, you stay brand loyal,
you pull into the Mcdonald's,
right?
You get gas at the fucking Sunoco
or whatever. You keep it fucking,
yeah.
You want to get breakfast.
Let's do you wanted to try the mom and
fucking pop place where everyone's going
to fucking turn around and look at you
or are we going to Denny's, you know?
Um,
anyways,
I really should be talking
about politics because I,
I literally do not watch any of it.
Um,
I know it was all that
bullshit with Trump.
I don't understand why people won't let
Trump speak and how you feel that that's
going to derail his campaign. I think
if anything, it will just strengthen it.
Um,
I'm sure there's probably plenty of
Trump people that don't like what Bernie
Sanders or Hillary saying they're not
going in there and literally disrupting
the whole fucking thing.
Right? I don't know.
Just seems stupid at me.
He sees a fucking reality TV show star.
Just let the guy talk who gives a shit.
He's not really saying anything.
He's appealing to some people.
Who the fuck votes in a primary anyways,
aren't you guys like me?
I vote once every fucking four years.
I hate to say it, but I do. I vote.
I vote for president.
That's who I vote for.
And I always vote for the
fucking the third party person.
Although I don't know about Bernie Santa.
I don't know if I'm going to fucking
vote for this guy. I'm just sick of it,
you know? Hey, you know,
we're going to take all the money from
fucking these 10 people and give it to
all you guys cause all you
guys deserve it right now.
You guys are lazy concert. Don't want to
pull their own way. You're all a joke.
Your angels send everybody up there
is devils right? That dumb shit.
It's just as extra. It's, it's
fucking Donald Trump to the left.
I can't listen to any of it. And then
sitting right in the fucking middle,
drafted behind both of them is all fucking
square head or Self Hillary Clinton,
she's gonna fuck. She's going to go right
in underneath, right in, underneath.
She's going to get in there and you're
going to have listened to that fucking
busted trumpet for fucking
the next four years.
Yeah.
Fucking filthy, filthy family. I don't
like any of them. All three of them.
You know what?
You have a c on the Donald Trump show
when he does like a combo firing.
You know what? You'll find? You're
fucking fired and you're fired.
That's what I would like to do with the
three of them. Dawson, when the fucking,
I could say that head on because I only
vote once every four years and I do not
watch the debates. All right, so, you
know, I'm standing on farm ground here.
Such a dope. Hey, you
know what I did do? Um,
God knows it wasn't read something.
Uh,
I, um, I watched on Netflix,
I watched that Ukraine documentary
a winter on fire. It, um,
you know, it was just one of those
things where it's just like Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I knew I wasn't politically active,
but watching what these people did,
what they turned around,
I'll,
I'll try to give you a simple version
of what happened, which, you know,
with my brain, that's all you're going
to get is basically what happened,
I guess around 2003, 2004, uh,
there was some fucking
Russian dude pro Russian dude.
He claimed that he won the fucking
election and they were like, no,
you didn't need a piece of shit.
You're rigged it.
And they proved it and
he got bounced on 2009,
the same dude comes back and guess what?
He wins the election like that
wasn't corrupt. So anyways,
the Ukraine has a chance to
join the European Union, right?
To start being more like a European
country and for once and for all get out
from underneath a, whatever you call,
whatever. Russia has a dictatorship.
So the fucking Russian dude who
allegedly got elected legitimately,
you know, listens to the people and
they say that that's what we want to do.
We don't want to take
a step towards Russia.
We want to become part of
the European Union. We want
to have a future here. Like,
um,
what we see going on in western Europe
and all of the fucking politicians go,
you got it. All right.
The people have spoken.
We're going to do what you said
and what do you think happened?
Right in the midnight hour they gave me
all right there, Fred. They're like, yeah,
you know what? We're not
sign to that. And, uh,
we're going to go hang out with
though Vladi daddy over there.
Potanin let them be in Nanana.
We're going to fucking shoot 18 holes
of golf with him and we're going to sell
out your country to the risky.
So started off this whole
fucking revolution. I'm not
going to say what the fuck.
I mean, you gotta watch it. It's
unbelievable. But, um, you know,
I mean, it's not like, it's not the
news. I mean they ended up winning.
The somehow ended up winning and these,
these fucking people had no weapons.
They were just getting shot
at what I don't understand.
I mean I do understand it, but I, I,
there's no place in the world where
you can protest. You can't do it.
You protest,
cops show up and they beat the fuck out
of you until you go home and they arrest
a few and then that's it. Every,
what happens in this country,
this country with all its all would
to fray brave freedom of speech.
You know those fucking occupy
Wall Street people, right?
They come down there,
they beat the fuck out of him and
everybody knows the old trick,
the same shit that they was.
They were claiming they did it in
the Ukraine where it basically,
when you have a peaceful
demonstration, it's like, well fuck,
we can't beat the fuck out of him.
What should we do?
They hire a couple people to go
down there and pretend to be,
the protest is they throw a couple of
fucking rocks and then the cops go nuts.
And then on the news, they're like the
protesters started attacking the police.
You know, the police were just doing
their job well, blah, blah, blah, blah.
The police's job is to go down there
and beat the fuck out of him. All right,
isn't it? Isn't that what it is that
Jesus Christ built? I don't know, Bill,
what do you know? I don't know. That's,
that's kind of what I got out of it.
I got out of it that,
um,
it was an amazing documentary that
these people actually with basically no
fucking weapons and just, you know, died,
lost their eyes, had all these horrific
fucking injuries, got kidnapped,
disappeared, all of this horrific
shit and they were able to,
um,
hold them off for a while.
So then the fucking Russian guy
ends up having to leave, right?
He fucking leaves and then the Yay Nay,
he's a jolly good fellow. It's all
fucking over. And then all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
this,
this other revolution starts
with people who are pro Russia.
So once again,
all they did was they just had Russian
troops pretend to be you crazy.
And just say, wait a minute,
we don't want to be free.
We to be oppressed. Right. So now I
guess they got to fight that thing.
It's since the, since the documentary we
made like 6,000 Ukrainian people died.
But um, well I don't, I
don't understand why a,
yeah.
If you just look at the
United States of America,
the amount of money you can still make,
if you're up on top,
the amount of taxes you can get out of
paying the amount of parks that you can
fuck and a half and just pass
it on to the middle class.
I don't understand why,
like why Russia is still does the whole
fucking a dictator thing or why any
country does just set it up the way
we set it up. You pretend that people,
you know, you give him, you know,
okay.
You let them be as free as
they could be, you know? Yeah.
You do the whole rhetoric out there,
but basically there is still a ruling
class and you don't have to pay your fair
share and all that fucking shades
works out and we know you're doing it.
But as long as you know, you let us
drive down the street and a convertible,
you know,
listening to some tunes, man by,
I mean somebody's got to run it.
I don't want to fucking do that shit.
You know,
all of a sudden make decisions.
I don't even like running my own website.
There's no fucking way I could be sitting
there making decisions for an a whole
goddamn country. I don't want
to do that. You know what,
uh, what, what the, what are the, what is,
what does that like every fucking day
waking up and not a God damn problem.
That's why the, I think thanks.
That's why he can't have a dictator.
That's why they're all so brutally mean.
After a while they just get sick
of answering questions. Why?
What's the problem where I have just
fucking shoot them all right. I don't,
I don't care.
I said fucking shovel.
Put 'em in jail. Fuck. I've got
to do everything around here.
She got here and about it
anyways.
So if you get a chance, I'll try to say
is if you get a chance check out, uh,
Ukraine,
winter on fire and um,
okay.
I Dunno. I, I should, you should really
start paying attention to politics more,
but I, I just think it's
all bullshit. I can't,
I can't sit there and listen to it.
I started screaming at the fucking TV.
MMM.
And I get all fucking upset.
So why would I do that?
And then I ended up with three fucking
options, none of which I want. You know,
I do have to tell you, watching
all fat boy, they're from
New Jersey. Jesus Christ,
the look on his face when he was
fucking listening to Donald Trump.
That was the funniest fucking shit ever.
That looked like a shotgun. Wedding
it all. He was thinking, is that
a fucking fuck? Do I get it?
I get myself into this. How do
I get out of this? You know,
AH,
Jesus Christ.
How much did he fucking binge
eat that night? Poor guy.
That's really bad.
It's gotta be,
you know what sucks about being fat
is people just know it. You know,
you can't hide that shit and just bomb it.
Just fucking write on it.
You know what? Me, I guess we, I'm a
baldheaded motherfucker so I got that now.
But when I was younger, well then I had
orange hair orange then turned red. Yeah.
You know, I kinda got shit the whole time,
you know, if I really look back at it.
Um, all right. Save you just some regular
brown haired Brunette fucking, you know.
Okay.
I'm just, you know, when you think about
Chinese people, right? Cause they don't,
they other, any redheaded like naturally
redheaded, naturally aspirated.
Um,
Chinese people hang on a second here.
Natural red head,
Chinese
nine natural redheads from different
backgrounds, the forever war.
Why a Chinese girl has red hair?
Well because there was a fucking
military base nearby, I would think.
All right. The forever war. Why
a Chinese girl has red hair.
When you zoom out of history to the level
where empires rise and fall and people
migrate, conquer, collapse
and absorb it disappear.
You find that the story
is always the same.
That the what?
The tall stock tie stock.
The original stock is light
non black hair. Non Brown eyes.
Fair skin.
Yeah.
Well am I on a racist website?
Don't fuck am I reading here?
MMM.
The others are darker. The
others are weaker but breed
faster. Ah, there we go. The,
I saw the red flags.
The fuck is the name of this website.
Co Anik. Soul life to the
neanderthal death to the void.
Okay.
Christis rex the forever war.
Why a Chinese girl has red hair.
Oh God.
Fucking Internet is amazing. And I just
affected, he just gives every glutamate,
just a bunch of fucking dopes.
Yeah.
Why are blonde and red
hair color not seen?
Can an Asian and a natural redhead if
have a redheaded Asian look at this shit.
The redheaded Chinese girl,
Asian red hair on Pinterest.
The world's first Asian redheads.
So I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
that they don't really don't have any
blondes or any of that type of shit.
So I was just thinking,
do you think that people get less
shit? Like, what do you get bullied for
in, uh, in China? Oh God,
please let to be some fucking
native Chinese people. This
does this. What are the,
give me the top fucking 10 reasons that
Chinese people get bullied in China.
Okay.
It's probably a usual shit.
Economic is going to be looks right.
There's always going to be
better looking mediocre.
And then there's always going to be some
poor bastard coming down the street.
You know, some fucking
happen. I don't know.
Something that's going on with his nose.
His fucking ears is there. The kids,
they'll, they'll, they'll find something.
Yeah, but you would think, you know,
if everybody just had the
fucking jet black hair,
and maybe I'm more overly sensitive
to this because I just came, you know,
I came on, I came in the
world with a bullseye. Right?
Right there, there you go.
What the fuck is that?
Get it right.
MMM.
This has been a fucking crazy podcasts.
I don't,
and I don't have any advertising yet.
I,
this is usually the time that I tap
out and I start fucking reading.
But it hasn't come in yet. It
has not come in yet. Let me see.
I'll look it up right now.
See if I got it.
Why don't I was at 50
fucking windows open. No,
I got a French book here that I
was reading. I wasn't reading.
I was listening to it.
It's a book.
Something about a wolf that
wanted to change its colors.
I've gone 15 or 16 straight
days on a dual lingo.
Asked me to say something in French.
I can't really, but you know what?
I can read it pretty well.
MMM.
For, I know that that means for children.
Poor off false children. All right.
What am I doing? I'm I completely
losing my train of thought here.
Oh fuck. He's something. He's a
window. This is the amount of shit.
I look out one window. I have
French school books. All right.
And then the next window I have
critical engine opened up on Wikipedia.
I was talking to Paul Versey cause we're
doing this tour and I was saying like,
all right,
these are going to be like four or five
hour drives or we could rent a small
plane but it's going to be maybe
two to sin. Paul's me, hello, hello.
I don't like small plane starts
freaking the fuck out. Right.
Like small planes sticking. It's like
a Chevy Chevette a piece of shit.
Like it's not,
it's going to die.
And I was saying like two but
it's going to be dual engine.
We're going to be fucking
fine. Uh, you got two engines.
I mean the odds of them both fucking
failing at the same time and one of them
can still fly the plane. You
fine. This is what I believed.
But then I started looking it up
cause I was trying to give them some
information. I was saying like, look, I
mean I don't know 100% know this ship.
This is what I've basically been told.
And a,
I started looking it up and evidently,
uh,
one engine for the most part is
more critical than the other.
And also when one engine goes out,
it isn't like he just keep flying it
normally. Well you know, we still got one.
We're good like that.
Obviously you know,
it fucks with the not the balance.
What would it be?
I don't know how to say it scientifically.
It's not a jet engine.
So there's no like thrust is
there? Ah, of Jesus Christ.
Can you believe I have a pilot's license
and fucking I believe. All right,
let's read this year.
Uh,
the critical engine of a multi-engine
fixed wing aircraft is the engines whose
failure would most adversely affect the
performance or handling abilities of an
aircraft on propeller aircraft.
There is a difference in the remaining
yawing and that's just the nose going
right to left moments after failure of
the left or the right outboard engine.
When all propellers rotate in
the same due to the p factor.
And I was like,
what the fuck is the p factor?
It has something to do with like when
you're flying straight and level flight.
Okay. Your propeller blades are, um,
you know,
they're there.
You got the angle of attack with the
wind is basically coming straight.
You're perpendicular to the
angle of attack of the wind.
That way you are getting the most bang
for your buck with for the work that the
engine is doing,
what the propellers.
But the more you angle nose up
or nose down, the more the wind,
the way it's hitting, it affects the
performance. It's what I sort of believe.
I got all this Mumbo jumbo in my fucking
head. I have no idea. But I had no, I,
so I started reading more about this
and there's all these fucking debates.
You know,
I was always of the belief
that if you had two engines,
if you could afford to engines,
you buy that fucking airplane because
you know the engines run independently.
So you got to fucking engines.
What are the odds of both of them?
One fails and then the other
one fucking fails, you know,
but it's it.
So it's gotta be almost zero.
However, there's all
these, I could, you know,
something I started to read about it and
there was all these debates where they,
at first it was obviously believe that
yeah, more engines is better, it's safer.
And then somewhere along the line somebody
did a study and saw that more fatal
action, uh, actions,
more fatal accidents happened in dual
engine aircraft and people were going
like, oh, and then so maybe a single is
better. And then that person came back.
It was like, no, you weren't
hearing what I was trying to say.
I was actually saying it was safe
and then it doubled back on itself.
And I have no fucking clue what is safe.
But what I did learn in it in a very
layman kind of way was I had no idea that,
um, I mean it does make sense if
you just have one side working,
you know that it'd be sort of pollen
that side along of the aircraft more so
than the other one causing the other one.
The drag and I, you'd have to, I dunno,
crab your way into the fucking wind.
I have no idea.
But all I know is I was reading it says
if one of your engines dies and the
other one's still going,
you obviously have a much,
they said a much better chance
of making it to the airport.
They didn't say you would make it though.
And a witch.
Here's my question to anybody out
there who might know this shit
on it,
on your average twin engine airplane,
can both, both engines
independently fly the airplane?
You know what I mean? With one quick,
do they both have the ability to,
uh,
can basically get,
have you flying fast enough where
you can still maintain lift?
You know, cause then I was
then thinking like, okay,
well if they went from one to two engines,
you know,
you're adding more weight to the aircraft.
Well I guess you'd build a
bigger fucking plane. Sorry,
I'm trying to do this math in my head.
You build a bigger fucking plane.
But my thing is is do they then go
all because of on certain aircraft,
because it's a cheaper twin engine.
It's the both engines in unison have
enough power so you can maintain lift.
But if you lose one of them,
the other one can't still give you the
hundred percent of the lift that you need.
You actually only have like 60% if you
still have the critical engine or only
40% of the critical one goes out.
Like I have no idea how it works.
All I know is it scared the fuck out
of me. That's all I can tell you. Um,
all right. Isn't it an amazing the
amount of topics I can talk about that.
I have no fucking idea. It's
incredible. Like we're, we're, we're,
we're going to be doing some more here in
the last half hour of this podcast. Um,
I guess now I'm,
I'm just gonna say that I'm going to
stop here and read some advertising.
I don't have it, but a, you're
going to hear it now because a,
you're listening to this
and the fucking few. Okay.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody,
and I'm recording this on my phone
if it sounds fucked up. All right.
Dollar Shave club.com has a
special offer for a new members,
for new members who join today.
You'll get a free month
of the executive razor.
When you buy a tube of doctor cabbies,
a missile, first time they've
ever done something like this.
And once you try dollar shave club.com,
you'll become a proud member
like millions of others. Uh,
one reason is because they deliver amazing
razors right to your door for a third
of the price of what those greedy
cut razor corporations charge.
That means when you
joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh
blade anytime you fucking God damn well
feel like,
and it feels fantastic.
You'll get a first class shave when you
use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet. Another reason is
their doctor cabbies Ega learn, uh,
using it with the executive,
uh,
makes the blade glide gently over
the smoothest shave ever. Hey,
you might want to shave your balls
with it. Don't do that. Don't do that.
Nobody at fucking skin shave here.
Dollar Shave Club is saying to fucking
do that. That was a joke. Okay.
Drop your razor and wash the coffee,
shave butter off of your ball bag.
Do not do it. All right. Back
to the ED. Dot. D cabbies.
Easy Shave.
It isn't your average shaving cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula with
high quality natural ingredients leaving.
You're leaving your skin unbelievably
soft and smooth. And right now,
members who buy a tube of shave butter,
get the executive razor razor for free.
They've never done this before.
Take advantage of it. And it's the, Oh,
it's only available by going
to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr.
All right, what's up next?
Oh, here we go. Are Old friends
are back headspace, man,
uh, let's honest, most of you, most of
your problems start with your mind. Jesus.
I know mine. Do. Fear, anger,
stress, anxiety, depression,
sleeplessness and freckles. They begin
in your head, taken wreck your life.
Um, please include all the falling points
during your read. I will, I always do.
Um,
but it doesn't have to be that way.
You can make a major difference
in just 10 minutes a day.
This change comes through a,
through guided meditation
with the new headspace APP.
Headspace man is meditation made simple.
It's guided meditation that you listen
to whenever you want, wherever you want,
right on your phone,
computer or tablet.
Beditation is rooted in thousands of
years of tradition and we've boiled it.
We've boiled it down to an APP that we
hope a bigger corporation will someday
pie so we can,
we can take the money,
get some huggers and a bunch of blow
with thousands of scientific studies that
show its positive effects,
like improving focus and relationship,
harmony in decreasing anxiety and stress.
Join over 5 million users already using
some headspace me and for free right
now.
Free download for free headspace,
the headspace APP and again to take their
take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation@headspace.com slash bro,
why don't I ever do this?
I need to do this.
I'm out of my fucking mind.
Their headspace take 10 program is 100%
free way to experience the benefits of
meditation and you're busy, modern
life. Train your mind for a healthier,
less stress life. That would
be great for me. You know,
I'd stop screaming at people,
I wouldn't be funny anymore and I'd
become homeless. But God damn it.
I'd be happy now. Seriously,
I want to do this.
headspace.com/birth that's
headspace.com/burr hey man,
headspace.com/ [inaudible]
fuck. There's two more. I hate
this. I hate doing these trunk club.
No matter what time of year it is. Yeah,
you've got to make every second count.
Oh Shit. I need to look good with this
zipper and that means looking your best.
No more ratty jeans are oversized hoodies.
Your dress like a fucking Douche. Gee,
wouldn't it be great if a trunk full
of clothes would come your way? Sure.
I know how you could do it.
Trunk Club Trunk Club takes the Hassles,
man out of shopping, finding the
best clothes for you and your style,
your look and feel amazing and you'll
always have the perfect close for the
season, but I don't want to
go to the fucking mall. Well,
that's the point of the ship@trunkclub.com
slash burr you answer simple
questions about your style,
your preferences, your size,
and you were assigned an expert stylist.
You styles is going to go pick up
all the shit that you asked for.
Then they're going to send you the
fucking trunk. You sift through it.
You keep the shit you like.
You give the shit back that you don't
like in their prepaid fucking trunk. Bing,
Bang, boom. You never have
to go to a mall again.
You've got to look great and God damn
it. You look great. You feel great.
Maybe it was subtle. Suck your Dick. Ah,
maybe you'll find your prince charming.
Sorry, I had to cut through all the copy.
Get started today and trunk club and a,
they'll style you for free.
He posts truncal free shipping both ways.
You only pay for the clothes
that you keep. Take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/burr that's trunk
club.com/ [inaudible] for a trunk filled
with clothes. You're going to love.
You don't have to go to the mall.
It's a fucking joke. Why you're not doing
it. I don't know. All right, blue apron,
everybody. You need to
know how to cook. Okay.
It's time you grow up
and learn how to cook.
Not only do you feel like you know
your way around a kitchen. Ooh,
who's feeling Sassy?
But cooking at home means eating
healthier and saving more money instead of
ordering out expensive takeout. Again,
payment. Where do you start? Well,
don't worry. Blue Apron as you're covered
for less than $10 per meal, blue apron,
blue apron delivers all fresh ingredients,
all the fresh ingredients you
need to create home cooked meals.
Just follow the easy step
by step instructions. Um,
each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the
grocery store. No more sad takeout,
no matter your dietary preferences.
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover
and prepared dishes like smokey maple,
miso glazed salmon with an what?
Udon noodles. Uh, dawn
noodles. You dawn noodles.
You'd on doodles.
U D o n noodles,
mushroom Kaylin cheese case,
a dia gross,
gross mushroom and Kale and cheese.
It's like watching a fat kid. He'd
paste. How about chicken and cheese?
I with Lyme, sesame,
avocado, radishes and salsa.
Right now when your own coach kitchen,
you can cook with a grease that you've
never used before. Like watermelon,
radishes, feral far. Oh fuck. Oh,
I don't know what it is with purple
potatoes and recipes are between five and
700 calories,
so you won't become a fat fuck.
Delicious and good for you right now.
You can get your first two meals for
free@blueapron.com slash bird that's blue
apron.com/bar blue apron.com/bar.
You know what?
It's a better way to cook, God dammit. And
there you go. Back to the podcast. Yeah,
in the future. All right. Um, oh,
I didn't even finish the fucking, I'm
back. We're back after the advertising.
We are back, I guess. Did I read it? Did
I sound good? How much did I stumble?
I never even finished
the frying pan story,
so I get all the way down to the
fucking frying panting. All right.
And we already have like the
regular whatever, a 10 inch one.
So I want to buy the eight
inch one that matches.
And of course the only way to do that
as that to buy the whole fucking set.
Okay.
You know, I was just like,
you know what? Fuck you.
And I bought one of those little
pasta cutter thinks and that was it.
And I fucking left.
And I called for the life of me,
could understand one of them was
nine 95 the other one was 21 bucks.
And I sat there for 10 minutes holding
both of them, trying to see like,
does it handle better?
How is this one more than twice the price?
I Dunno. Bill, why would you think
it's interesting to us? I don't know.
Trying to fill up a fucking hour here,
by the way.
Okay.
By the way, I got some, I have,
I do have some dates and I will never
again announced cities, um, that I,
that I'm saying, you know, we're working
on it. I'm never going to do that again.
Like I said,
what I said with buffalo
and fucking Syracuse because
that hasn't worked out yet.
Now everybody's like, dude, what the
fuck you said you will come in there.
I shouldn't open my
big Yap. All right. Um,
I am coming to Albany.
I do know that.
So people in Buffalo, like, dude, that's
like a four hour fucking drive. I know.
I know. I'm sorry. All right. I'll, I'll,
I'll figure something out. All right.
Here we go. On match 25th
I'm in Riverside, California,
Riverside,
which I believe is the beginning of
the inland empire or maybe it isn't.
I have no idea.
Um,
on the 26th I'm at the terrorists
theatre in Long Beach, California.
Unbelievable honor to be playing in a
place that is the place where Richard
Pryor taped live in concert
where he had the red shirt,
the black pants and the silver shoes.
I will be standing on that stage.
I'm sure they redid it since
he's been there, you know,
so I won't be standing on
the exact same floorboards,
but I will be within the same structure.
It would be standing in the same place
where he did standup comedy to me,
the greatest standup comedian of
all time on the 22nd of April.
I will be in Saint Louis the oh ago.
Y'All on the 24th.
He's a great ones.
I will be in Iowa in
Ames, Iowa, 20 seconds.
St Louis, Missouri and the
24th there'll be an ames, Iowa.
I have not been an ios since I did
the rich bitch tour way back in 2004.
Um, speaking of which, to anybody's Dick,
one of the guys that did the
tour with Darnell Rawlings,
did you see that TMZ video?
The guy's getting breakfast.
It's got a $12 check.
He goes outside to have a cigarette.
He leaves his bag inside and all of a
sudden they came running out in Philly
screaming and I'm thinking he was,
he was, he was dining and dashing,
but showing it as we used to call
it in Boston. You know what I mean?
Fucking unbelievable.
Unbelieving.
The ends up getting in a big
fucking fight and I'll, let's see,
he's got his bag inside.
They won't give it to them.
MMM.
According to the shit that I read
and it's just fucking unbelievable.
I can tell you that as a white guy,
that would not happen to me.
That would not happen to me. Um,
that, that was, that was fucked up.
Definitely fucked up. And
uh, you know what? It didn't
happen in Boston. All right.
All you fucking haters that happened
in Philly sake. It's all around.
MMM.
You know, it was funny. Donald threw
that punch in. The dude caught it.
Yeah.
The next time I see him,
I'm going to tease him about that.
I wouldn't do it now because it's
fucking fresh and it was bullshit. I can,
I can definitely tell you as a
white dude, uh, that you know,
that not we would not have happened to me.
That's a complete racial
profiling incident,
but it was dead fucking dude lean
back and just caught it. You know,
you ever see a picture?
Just catch a fucking one that comes
right back to the mound. He did that.
But with Darnell fist, um, anyways, uh,
plowed ahead. Uh, May
7th, Orlando, Florida,
May 8th. I'll be in Jacksonville, Florida.
And a clear, what are you staring
at before? What's the matter?
I'm not,
I already gave you f o o d so let me look
at me like that and I already took you
out. Um, well you just
want attention buddy.
You're getting lonely over there,
Huh?
All right.
Fucking dog is so needy.
All right. Portland May,
June 4th, 2016 I'll be there. Uh,
and I also know I in the early April,
I got a bunch of Canadian dates. Uh,
they're all up on my website.
[inaudible] DOT com. Um, so anyways,
speaking of dogs, I kind of tweeted
about this shit where, um, you know what?
The fucking dog,
I have the biggest problem with,
like their owners never have money
control. I'm not blaming the breed here,
but there's just something
about the fucking the owners
and how hyper the dog is,
is those fucking giant poodles.
There was another one today.
I was at the supermarket.
This person had tied it up outside and
it's just literally outside the fucking
supermarket the whole time.
Okay.
Route, route, route, route.
You just would not stop. Sorry.
I get my dog all amped up. Um,
those fucking dogs are insane. I don't
know what the deal is with them be,
did they? I think they are like,
they're kind of like greyhounds.
I really just think you need to run
them around a fucking track for an hour
every day just to get them to
get it out of their system.
But they got like that palm going on.
So I don't think anybody really thinks
it's an issue. Clear. What are you doing?
You're going to distract
me on the podcast. He can't
be this adorable right now.
Okay. For those of you don't
know anything about pit bulls,
they are like the most needy
fucking like love bugs.
They're ridiculous.
Like she just wants to crawl up here and
fucking put her head in my lap and go
to sleep.
You know what I mean?
She's not over in the corner of fucking
doing some prison workout thinking about,
you know, people she wants to
kill right now. Right Buddy.
Now that I've stereotyped giant poodles,
I'm going to try to undo
the damage with pit bulls.
Who's getting all my dog would try to
rip your face off if he came into the
fucking
end of the house.
She fucking barked at a guy yesterday
and I actually loved every second of it.
I was sitting in my Prius on
these mean streets of Los Angeles,
downtown Hollywood.
And uh,
some fucking degenerate came
up to the window and uh,
I don't know what the fuck he's asking
for money or booze or some shit.
And my dog just fucking flipped out,
flipped out and the guy jumped
back and everything was great.
It's like having my own security.
Um,
and the guy was such a fucking alkie
d backed up off the car and then still
mimed like I want to drink,
I'm trying to get some money for drinks.
I just, you know, I told him the beat it
every once in a while to tell him to be,
you know, there was a one legged homeless
guy and he seemed like he was saying,
and he was talking to himself.
Maybe it was a little crazy,
but I will be talking to myself too if
I had one fucking leg standing next to a
stop sign. Right. What else are you going
to do? There's nobody else there. So him,
I gave money to.
Okay.
And I was actually joking to myself when
I gave him the money and I drove away.
I go high. There's, there's my good deed
for the day. Hey, let's go in and rub it.
Tongue
rub and tug.
I can't believe fucking
people go to those places.
Math that don't you worry that the cops
are gonna show up any second, you know,
you lie in there with the fucking woody,
right?
With a little fucking Woodrow Wilson,
Some girl fucking giving you real handy
and all of a sudden everybody get down
to the ground, you know, you're like, oh
shit. Right. And what are you going to do?
Say it was legal.
You're not a will that hard on to go away
before that fucking dude comes in and
sees you with a half his stiffy, you
know, I swear to God it hangs like that.
I was in here. I had a
problem with my shoulder, man,
they're going to arrest you.
Is she a fucking half naked?
Bring it down to the jail.
You're already ready to get fucked.
You don't even have any clothes on.
He got an oil all over your body. The
fuck is wrong with you. So anyways,
June 5th, I'll be in Albany,
New York and a June 17th,
I'll be in,
no.
Okay.
No work. Fucking New Jersey at the, uh,
New Jersey fucking performance
arts center for the, uh,
the fucking cock suck is there.
Um,
okay.
You don't really make me happy. The
other day I was watching the NHL channel.
Obviously they were talking about how
the Bruins could potentially get the
number one seed in the east.
Unfucking believable the job
that Clode Julian has done.
And I'll tell you something right now,
Dan Shaughnessy,
you remember last year when you were
calling for his fucking head and saying
maybe he stayed here too long.
You all went on and on.
You should write an apology article.
Unbelievable how these
fucking sports writers,
because they got nothing else to
write. We'll, we'll try to run out,
run out of town,
a fucking coach who brings us our first
Stanley Cup and almost 40 fucking years.
Why would you do that?
Yeah.
Jesus fucking Christ. Why would
you do that? All right, let's, uh,
let's read some of the, uh, the questions
here for this week. Oh, we got an update.
I love when there's an update number last
week, the, uh, the granny fucking war.
Yeah.
No. But that story all right
here, we got an update. Hey,
they're all Billy fucking water.
I got an update for you on this one. Uh,
the story has good news and bad news.
All right, so last, last week, for
those of you who didn't listen,
I'll give you a little recap. There
was some kid, uh, you know, he was,
he's basically, he's engaged,
he's getting married in six weeks,
so he's over his fiance's house
as it was future in laws house,
her fucking parents. That's
all I'm trying to say, right?
So they're playing some card game and
evidently they're down to the final hand
and he has, uh, the cards
called granny water.
I don't know what the game is or whatever.
Some people sent me pictures of
the car at the game does exist,
but it's a really high point card
or whatever. And he was laying down,
ah, fuck, I'm yon and sorry. He
was laying down his card last.
I basically, when he laid it down, he was
going to do the old fucking right there.
Fred.
I won the game and uh,
he had the grantee water card and I guess
in the end of the game is probably the,
you get it, you hold onto it and
you played at a crucial point.
So everybody's sitting there as
everybody's laying the cards down,
waiting to see who's going
to fucking lay it down.
So this kid fucking finally his turn,
he lays it down to be like, you know,
like hitting the last second three,
I just won.
And because he listens to the podcast,
instead of saying,
I got the grantee water card,
he goes, he goes, look, he goes,
it's all fucking grant now. He
goes, it's granny fucking wall.
And just screamed it
to his in laws.
Okay, who never heard this guy curse
before and do not listen to this podcast?
So they just stared at him
like, what? What was that?
What is my daughter marrying?
Like he just completely screwed
the whole fucking thing up.
So he's asking me for advice. Should he
bring it up? Should he not bring it up?
All right, now you guys
are caught up. Here he go.
He says the story has
good news and bad news.
The good news is my fiance's parents
were super cool about the whole thing.
Um,
I bit the bullet and waited until we went
over for game night again last night.
I apologized, of course, and they
said they initially just thought,
why or where you're like this?
Fuck.
They initially thought it was really
odd for me to yell like that without
knowing, without them knowing the
context. The once it was explained,
my fiance texted them about it. It
was no big deal. It was a huge relief.
We played the game again and every
time someone played that card,
they did the whole granny water thing
minus the fucking in the middle.
Okay, cool. He goes, so my
embarrassment will be immortalized. Uh,
the bad news is that I mentioned that
you read the letter on the podcast.
Oh No. You know what? You're
one of those guys, dude,
you just like, you just like
stepping in shit. He goes naturally.
They wanted to listen to it.
I thought it wasn't a big deal because
they lived through the story and your
commentary was hilarious.
I warn them about the explicit nature
of your podcasts and that there were
plenty of fucks throughout.
The fact that he did grantee water
thing before it was even brought up,
uh, was perfect. And everyone
thought the story was hilarious.
That is until the p s
uh,
if you recall, I may or may have not
called Hillary Clinton a current,
uh, Jesus. That's right. You
did. He goes, yeah, I know.
I'm a dumb ass bill. My fiance just
turned to me and said, did you write that?
Uh, he said, my fiance
turned to me and said,
did you write that with that look
on her face? I knew I was fucked.
So freckles. I did the only
thing I could, I said, oh,
sorry about that. I didn't write
it. Bill's email screener guide did,
Andrew did, he picks the emails each
week, then writes the little opening line,
pun,
and then sometimes throws in a ps to
make them more in attaining when I,
why would you write this? Cause if
they listen to this, you're fucked.
If you don't do it, I have no sympathy
for you. So here we go. He goes,
they bought it.
So we just listened to the rest and
we're laughing again by the end.
So I through Andrew under
the bus on that one.
I'm going to repeat my only good move
from the last story and just shut the fuck
up about it forever in the end.
All is well.
Thanks for reading it on the podcast.
It seemed to help smooth it over.
No worries. Just tell him not to listen
to this one. He goes, by the way,
um,
I just bought tickets to your show and
I'm not going to say where the show is in
case anybody's figuring
out what the fuck this is.
It's the week after my wedding and my
fiance slash wife by that point is coming
too. I'd love to meet you in person.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Uh,
all right,
well you know,
I'll be hanging out after the Iowa.
Just scream out. Oh, I
just said where it was,
how well you fucked granny
water. Screaming out and
I'll fucking say allodia.
All right, now everybody's going
to do that there. All right,
girlfriend leaving cleo.
Relax buddy.
Go cold. You knows this. It's
usually not cold at night.
You got a little gas left in the tank.
Hockey. You want to go? Oh, I know. Okay.
I got it. I'm not going to say
the whole sentence. I will.
I'm going to take you know who you know
where when I'm done with this. All right,
cool. Yoko lay down, buddy.
Could you please lay down?
I don't have it in my heart to
yell at you here. All right, cool.
Could you lay down your fucking
[inaudible] looking to get out. Go on.
Go on please.
Can you lay down please cleo?
Yeah.
Yeah. Step on all my shit. As you
go over there, just go lay down
Jesus dog. Whisper. I am
not. Um, oh, by the way,
how about those fucking concert wounded
warriors? How much money did I give them?
If they're actual pieces of shit over
there and they didn't give that fucking
money to wounded troops,
you know,
can I sue them to get the money back and
then just give it to the fucking people
they were allegedly going to help?
Okay.
I am really just, I'm done. I'm
done with fucking charities.
I'm fucking done with them.
I just damn eight. Oh,
I'm going Donald Trump on this one.
I've seen two or three bad ones and
I'm judging all of them. Fuck them.
Saint Jude, I'm sticking with them. Okay.
If they ended up turning foot that bad,
then fuck all of them. I'm just doing
why I'm doing what I did the other day.
Drove up to somebody with
one leg at a stoplight,
observed that they weren't fucking
wasted as much as I could tell in.
There you go. You know, even if they were,
I'd be drinking too if I had one leg.
Right standing at a fucking stop sign.
Um,
I know what the stop sign has to do with
it. What was the traffic light fill?
Well, they need all, maybe
I have some yogurt, um,
girlfriend leaving for religious mission.
Hey,
Billy Ball bag.
My girlfriend and I are both college
students and although we haven't been
together for too long,
I could tell she is special in the way.
When you meet the one,
you just know she's the person I have.
She's the best person I've ever met. Kind,
funny, intelligent. And on top of that,
just drop dead gorgeous. What?
Jesus locked that down to. Um,
if things seem to be too good to true,
what if things seem too good to
be true? Jesus Christ, I have.
So I got to have some form of fucking
mild dyslexia or how many even dealt with
it. I thought he is a reform. Uh, uh,
things seem too good to be true. They are.
She's Mormon.
Oh
g
and she's leaving for her mission in July.
If you don't know Mormons,
I don't give a shit about Mormons and
just anybody who is actively religious,
you know, to the point it, it,
it affects the decisions they make in life
other than basic shit. Like, you know,
don't throw a rocket that guy, cause
you wouldn't want him to do it to you.
You know, I am at one
with that. But you know,
when you start forming other
opinions on your fucking religion,
it starts to get a little,
a little a scion taller.
Christie, Judy, Buddha,
fucking Newsom, whatever it, all of them.
Throw them all in one fucking Maslovian
is a big fucking party and stick it on a
fucker part, right? Yeah.
There you go. Show me the
microwave. Right. Turn it on it.
Don't shut it off.
All right.
She's a Mormon and she's leaving for
her mission in July. If you don't know,
Mormons are a type of Christian.
I didn't know that and they
send missionaries around
the world to convert people
into their religion and she's
getting sent to Zimbabwe.
Fucking Zimbabwe.
They leave for two years.
Have to pay for everything themselves
and aren't allowed to contact home the
entire time.
Yeah.
Why aren't they allowed to
contact home the entire time?
Yeah.
That's fucking weird. If she goes,
not only would that be the end of us,
but it's seriously hurts.
Chances of her future career aspiration.
We both want to become doctors.
I'm an atheist,
but I've recently found myself praying
to Jesus that she doesn't actually go
because if and when she leaves,
that will be the end of it.
I don't know what to do.
Should I break things off now?
Should I try and convince
her not to go waiting?
Is Not an option for me because we'd be
completely different people by the time
she gets back. Thanks
and go fuck yourself. Um,
I dunno dude. I'm starting to think
maybe she isn't the one for you.
If you're just gonna, you know, if
you have to debate telling her not,
should I just break it off or
tell her not to go? I mean,
I think if she really loved this woman,
you would you be going,
I'm just going to talk to you
until I'm blue in the face
and tell her not to go. And then even
if she went, you'd be thinking like,
well maybe you know,
you'd have a rail light going.
Well maybe to two years.
I don't know if we agreed a
fucking cool it for two years.
You know, it's only two years. When
you look at the rest of your life,
you kind of like,
hey,
we'd be two completely different
people as they pick it up now.
Yeah. Look, she wants to go
to Zimbabwe, her, you know,
to spread the fucking word of a whatever
the fuck they're doing there. Yeah.
Let her go. Just, you
know what he looks at.
Somebody wants to go somewhere to go do
something and what are you going to tell
him not to go? Go ahead.
Yeah, go ahead. Go.
Go. Spread the fucking dumb shit
they put in your head and go, go, go.
Spread it on the other side of
the world's poor fucking Zimbabwe.
Peep Zimbabwean people. And he
went fucking Zimbabwe. Yeah,
and I was assuming you meant because
it's so far away you couldn't visit her.
Let's see what's going on in
Zimbabwe right now. Zim. Bob,
way as exactly how it should
be spelled. Z I m B A. Bwe.
I'd be such a great fucking speller if
everything was spelled like Zimbabwe.
Zimbabwe's Z I m B A, B, Wwii,
Zimbabwe,
Z.
Soon we'll be converting you to more men
do, do, do you got to go two years
of your life to fucking for what?
All right.
Zimbabwe.
Zimbabwe's a beautiful country and
southern Africa that is known for its
dramatic a way. Wait, wait, wait.
Come on. Oh, this is the government.
It's the government website. So this
is all the propaganda here. Yeah,
it's absolutely beautiful. You can have
your wallet, fucking tape your chest.
No one will take it.
Everybody's wonderful down here.
Everybody's welcome.
Please come down and spend
all your fucking money. You
know, if you don't mind.
Okay.
Zimbabwe was voted the number one place
in Zimbabwe to go three years in a row.
Wow. Jesus, look at that. Fuck. That
puts Niagara Falls to shame. Holy Shit.
Zimbabwe's a beautiful country in southern
Africa that is known for its dramatic
landscapes. Diverse wildlife,
see Cobras and tigers,
and it's hard working. People home
do the Great Zimbabwe Monument,
the mighty Victorian falls and
the majestic eastern highlands.
The country also boasts of worldclass
national parks in which a variety of
animals, including the big five
can be fired. The Big Five.
What the fuck are the big five?
Yeah,
Big Five. I've got to go
lion. Who's your big five?
It's like the Chris rock movie top five.
Give me a big five.
I'd say the big five a.
You gotta go lion. Tiger.
Elephant doubt a doubt,
right?
That's like Montana. Brady can Johnny
Unitas the third one? You never know,
right? Whatever. They're there
were in everybody's top five.
If you know anything about football,
right? All right. Lion, tiger, elephant,
hippos, rhinos. Giraffes are big
gorillas. Some big motherfuckers. Hang
on a second. I got to look up big five.
They see, this is how you
do it. Well, you know,
I'm going to get the sports club
big. Five sporting good, big five
animals.
Okay.
In Africa. All right. In Africa,
the big five game animals are
okay.
The African Lion,
the African elephant is African.
You know like what it's supposed to.
What the Rhode Island one, the one
at the fucking zoo. The Cape Buffalo.
Ah,
the African Leopard
and the white slash black rhinoceros.
All right, so I've got three out of it.
Hippo. Rhino. Well, what the
fuck's the Hippel big five game.
All right. And Africa, the big five game
animals are American. Okay. The line,
the elephant, the Buffalo, the
leopard, and the rhinoceros. Oh,
is this the thing that dentists pay
to fly over and go fucking shoot these
things? All right. All
right, so there you go.
So we learned a little something
here. That's the big five. A,
the largest of these are the national
park in the west and the something else
transfrontier park in the south
has a total area of three and nine.
Is that it ends. Yeah. All
right, let's get to the, let's
get to the real questions.
Okay.
Um,
Americans welcome
in Zimbabwe.
Okay.
Did we do anything?
Did,
did the upper 1% in this
country piss them off?
All right. Americans in Zimbabwe that,
that at the de and I say, hey, looking
for fellow Americans in Zimbabwe.
No,
I'm not looking for a fucking pen pal.
Yeah.
Six things I had wrong. Cause last
thing I read about Zimbabwe. Alright.
Six things I had wrong
about traveling to Zimbabwe.
Look at those elephants and
fucking love those shoes.
I cannot believe people kill those things.
How could you kill an elephant?
I couldn't kill any of
those fucking things.
MMM.
All right.
The top five things.
Six things I had wrong about traveling
to Zimbabwe and one I had right?
Number one, Zimbabwe's dangerous. Uh,
at Matador we believe most
travel advisories in American
perceptions of overseas
destination being dangerous
are way overblown. I enjoy
visiting. Say that Dah, Dah.
The big cities.
MMM.
The big cities are the are where the most
violent crime is concentrated like in
the United States.
It wasn't a surprise that then that
Victoria Falls as well as the couple of
national parks we visited fell to just
about a safe and is friendly is any place
can get,
in fact,
Victoria Falls has such a small town
feel that other journalists joked.
It had the vibe of US national park
in the off season. All right, cool.
Zimbabwe's wildlife has all been
wiped out. This was a big one for me.
I love seeing wildlife.
This is making me want to go there.
Three hyperinflation will make
buying things a total hassle.
You have to sing years of news coverage,
hyperinflation, and I was fixing him.
I'd have to carry around bricks of $10,
$10 billion notes to buy a bunch of beer
at the currency of Zimbabwe has become
so worthless.
They've retired it completely,
and the country now operates
at a mist of foreign currency,
including the South Africa, k beyond the
wildlife. There's not much to do or see.
There's rafting,
bungee jumping.
Microlight flying over victory
fall fishing. Swimming.
All right, well, what the fuck did you
get? Right? I'm not reading all this shit.
Look at this fucking video. Swimming and
Victoria Falls. Get the fuck Outta here.
Okay.
This is this thing that looks like
it's bigger than Niagara Falls.
No fucking way.
Okay,
so basically the water isn't flowing
fast enough to these fucking got, okay.
I got to put us in a link to this video.
Okay.
Who is the absolute fucking psycho
that figured out you could do that?
Dude, if you just saw the
pasty fat fucking white dude
who just jumped in there.
You know, it's funny. He's there
with two fucking two black guys, man.
It'd be funny if they grabbed him and
threw him over. That was for slavery.
All right, let me, uh, all
right. I got a copy of that.
Jesus Christ. What a fucking
low in it. There's no, no
way. There's no fucking way.
No fucking way. All right, let's get back
to the, uh, the things here. All right.
MMM.
Where am I? All right. Tinder. Oh, Billy.
Let's read some emails for the week.
Uh, I hooked up with this girl I
met on Tinder the first in years.
I'm not a bad looking guy.
I think I just suck at small
talk over or over text any who.
This girl is 21 I didn't expect it
to go anywhere after we matched up,
we ended up hooking up. She's really
cool. You've hung out a few times since.
My friend and his girlfriend
started saying that was gross.
Uh,
I am 30 years old now.
I know my friend is being lame because
his girlfriend was there but gross not at
all. So I let them have their
ignorant opinions. Then I
dropped the facts of them.
She looks more like she's 24 through
this really isn't helping you.
I look like I'm 25 that's
also not helping you.
She took extra classes to graduate
college early and is already accepted into
medical schools. Still not helping you.
She speaks four languages fluently. Oh,
I see what you're saying. She's not a
dumb fuck. She knows what she's doing.
I don't mean hello and goodbye.
She can carry on full on con
conversations in Mandarin,
French and Italian as well as English.
Of course,
she has much better table manners then
both of them. Oh, you said that. Wow.
If you just torched the whole friendship.
I pointed this out to
my friend's girlfriend.
It didn't have a Napkin on her lap and
her elbows were on the table and pointed.
Okay.
That very fact out to her as well.
Also,
I mentioned that when me and
this girl met for a drink,
she put her napkin on her lap before
she bought her drink to her mouth.
Uh, which would have hovered over
her lap awareness levels maximum.
A 21. Who gives a fuck? I like to think
I'm right and then I made a good point,
but I need the opinion of
your honor. Billy burr. Uh,
yeah. Fuck. Damn. You're 30.
She's 21 who gives a shit good for you.
You're fucking crushing it.
She's a fucking adult and a,
she's not a dope.
You didn't roof here and there too.
Miserable fucks in a relationship. Right.
We've got food coming out of
the side of their mouth. Carrie.
All right. My kid wants to play
football. Hey, Billy Bella,
check Bella. Bella. Lik, um,
okay.
I'm a huge football fan. Watch
every week. Yada, Yada, Yada.
My kid is seven and loves it too.
He plays baseball and
basketball and it's really fast.
We played catch with a football
in the yard and he's really fast,
which has given him the desire
to be a wide receiver. Granted,
it's not the worst powder
you can get on the field.
I don't want to play football.
Uh, he's a great athlete,
but I'm not one of those delusional dads
who thinks he's going pro in whatever
he does. He's not small, but definitely
not the biggest of his age group.
How do I not sound like a cranky old man
or worried old mother and explained to
him how it's not worth it?
Should I just show him footage from a
30 for 30 to scare the shit out of him?
Oh Man. Dude, that is such a, um,
contemporary question, relevant
question, whatever, you know. Um,
okay.
I would actually defer this to
the Internet, believe it or not.
And then you have to use your own
judgment as to whether you're listening to
somebody who is informed and or somebody
who isn't you can you do like a middle
ground and maybe hockey, maybe you can
get them into hockey I guess so you, you,
you'd have to like hockey if
you don't like hockey. Um,
cause it would have the physical
aspects of it. But um, those guys don't,
don't fucking slam into
each other every play. Um,
you know what dude,
I don't know how to bring that up.
I would just be honest with
them and just say, listen,
I don't want to seem
like a cranky old man.
I don't want to seem like a worried
mother like you just said. But um,
I'm really worried about
the longterm effects
of you playing football.
And I would even say longterm effects
talk to him like an adult. Just say, yeah,
I am worried that you know, you,
if you get hit the wrong way,
God forbid people get paralyzed,
people die.
People have fucking don't say fucking
people that have brain injuries.
I would go down that road and just,
I would just say to the kid,
yeah,
your concerns and if he
really wants to fucking play,
then you know, you just do it. Peyton,
did you just get some
roids sent to your house?
You put them in your wife's
name and you get this kid,
you let them do a cycle right before the
season starts and you let him kick the
fuck out of somebody else's kid and
that shows right. There you go. Okay.
I'm just fucking around. Obviously.
The first thing I said I would,
I would seek more information on that
and figure out how you do it in the best
way. All right, Peyton, my
house, ma'am. Dearest Bill,
my house needs painting.
It has about six years.
It's been about six years since it's
been painted. We moved in four years ago.
I've painted a house before by,
my wife thinks I'm going to fuck
it up and or it will take too long.
You know what? I'm with her
already. Uh, I've been telling
her that I, I'll say, oh,
it'll save thousands of dollars.
She says that's not the point.
She's right. It's not entirely
the point. I make good money.
I just want to paint the house.
It's my first house and I feel the need
to do something to leave my mark on it,
literally and figuratively
speaking. Um, I'll to,
it'll take me about three weeks to do
the whole house. Not working every day,
but three,
four days a week.
I have a neighbor who's going
to be home from college,
who I've introduced to music
and he's never heard. Oh,
listen to him to music he's never heard.
So it's a great excuse to give the kid
a few bucks while introducing him to
early Soundgarden and Jane's Addiction.
Uh, she started bringing things up like,
well, what if it starts raining?
She's got nothing left on this one.
I have to paint my house. It's not a
manly thing. It's not to prove a point.
It's taking pride and ownership thoughts
on this. I say, you listen to your wife,
don't you want to do some fucking,
you finish your garage to
something like that. Okay.
Do something in there where it's a
part of a room that she doesn't have to
fucking deal with. Just have some pros
come over there, have them knock it out,
have them charge it to the fucking nose
and you sit inside drinking a fucking
beer. All right. This other shit
that you can do on the house.
Um, you know, I just
Peyton a fucking houses. That's a
big one, dude. That is a big one.
I understand that you want to do it?
MMM.
But yeah, I, I'm with you wife
on this one too. You know,
you already got a fucking job. Okay. You
make it good money. Pay Somebody to do it.
All right.
This is a bunch of shit on my house
that I started to do and I just started
thinking, you know what? I'm
making a good living. Fuck this.
Why don't I have a pro come over.
I can do it. I can figure it out.
Was patching up holes in walls.
I was learning how to do that shit.
You know,
I was fucking fixing the j trap under my
sink and doing all of that fucking crap.
It did learn all of that shit.
My last department.
Then I got to the house and it's like,
all right,
well I can do this or I can have a
pro come over here and do it and do it
fucking right. Okay. Now I'm
speaking for myself here.
My house was fucking wall toward
wall floor to ceiling inside and out.
Do it yourself. Fucking
hacks. All right. And
I wasn't going to carry
that fucking baton anymore.
Everything that I have had done on
my house has been done by fucking
professionals and my house is
as much as I bitch about it.
MMM.
It's 70% this shit at this point.
It really is. We'll take it,
this garage done and then I
got my kitchen's fucked up.
Don't even get me started with all
the exterior doors and windows. Okay.
In the wood rot and some of the
other shit I have to deal with.
But generally speaking, like this
fucking place is solid and I dunno, dude,
fuck that dude. You don't go a
fucking ladder. You know what I mean?
Mixing the Goddamn paint,
doing all of that bullshit. Um,
I would just,
I would,
yeah,
just, just pay for it. Just pay for it
and just say this bull is what you do.
Don't just do it. Just don't do what
your wife says. Get something out of it.
All right. Be like, alright, you
know what I thought about it.
I don't agree with it,
but I know that you would feel
better if somebody else did it. Okay.
So I am going to hire a
professional company to paint
the house and she be like,
okay, good. And I'll be like, I'm
not finished. I'm not finished.
However,
because I am doing that,
I am going to Redo the garage and the
garage is going to be a place where me and
my friends, we play poker and
we smoked cigars once a week.
I'm gonna have my own fridge in there
that's going to be a lock on the door that
you do not have a key
for. When you see, um,
exotic women walking in and out of that,
you are not to ask questions.
Is this understood?
Right?
You just say crazy shit like
that right over the fucking top.
And then she's done laughing. Then you
say, what the fuck you really want?
It will pale in comparison to fucking
exotic women walking in and out of your
garage and you'll be fucking in.
So I would think about what else you want.
All right. And at the end of the fucking
day, you're going to get something.
You want somebody else going to pay
your house, paint, uh, paint your house.
I think you're going to win personally
speaking. That's what I think. All right.
And you know what, that's a
podcast for this week, mother. Um,
thank you for listening as always and
I'm really excited about all these dates
that I have coming up and uh,
I,
I cannot fucking wait to go to Iowa.
I'm so excited about the Saint Louis.
Some of the great fucking sports fans
I've ever met my life or in Saint Louis
and God knows they got enough Budweiser's.
Long Beach is fucking,
uh, the Goddamn motherfucking
Richard Pryor Gig. Riverside,
Riverside, California. I
fucking, you know, when I was
learning how to fly, I had,
I had the land then when I did
the fucking French valley flight,
head of flight or Riverside,
they're not the French valley
and back to Long Beach. Um, shit,
I might fly over there. That
would be awesome. Um, ames,
Iowa obviously cannot wait to go to
there or Lando haven't been there in a
minute. Jacksonville, Florida.
The last time I was there and went to a
gun gun range and shut fucking guns with
silencers, he think I'm not going
to do that again. Portland, Maine,
my old stomping grounds.
Albany, New York, Newark,
New Jersey. These are all
places I love all those places.
I can't wait to get out there.
I've been working my ass off on my act.
If he come out, I'm gonna make you
laugh your fucking ass off. Okay.
So if you can make it, I would
really appreciate it. All right.
And I'm actually trying
to think of a tour name.
If you can come up with a name for it, you
know, cause these dates. I'm in Canada,
I'm in North America. I'm in fucking,
you know what? Canada's North America.
I'm in the United States of America,
right? I'm on the east coast.
I'm in the Midwest. I'm in the south.
I can't think of a name for the tour.
I don't know why I have to name the tour,
but my agent says I got to
come up with a name for it.
Something in the checking in on your
tour. I don't, I don't know what,
if you guys got on any ideas, just
tweet them to me, uh, at Bill Burr,
whatever the, I don't even know
what my Twitter is. You know what?
I don't even know where it
is. So whatever. If you've
got time to look it up,
send it to me. If you don't, I
understand. All right. Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you on Thursday.